le département de La Réunion au côté des
réunionnés le transport scolaire des
élèves et étudiants en situation de
handicap est une compétence obligatoire
du
[Musique]
département à qui
s'adresse-t-il
les élèves ou étudiants porteurs d'un
handicap peuvent être transportés
gratuitement vers les établissements
d'enseignement et ce quel que soit leur
lieu de résidence pour les parents qui
assurent eux même le transport scolaire
de leur enfant ils peuvent prétendre à
une indemnisation des frais de transport
pour bénéficier de ce dispositif l'élève
ou l'étudiant doit être titulaire d'une
notification de la cdap avec un avis
favorable pour le transport scolaire
adapté pour avoir plus de précision sur
cette aide rendez-vous sur le site
internet du département de La Réunion au
www.cg974.fr rubrique transport et route
vous pouvez également contacter le
service des transports au 0262 90 04 44
pour l'antenne Nord et au 0262 96 43 41
pour l'antenne
Sud les inscriptions sont ouvertes
jusqu'au 15 juillet prochain pour
l'année scolaire 2017
[Musique]